10 ма 1000 канати британці
позитивності виходити євросоюзу
обидва членство є євро skype так і
шанують і поки ви зберігати явної вдалося
і скоро ти ти види риб із суперниками
харчування виходу з України
вигляд британська публіка завжди була і
буду прагматичне у своїх пір ядерної
Європу знімає таку масивну
прихильність їжу з якунина чини
а компанія за на ось батько його аргументи
Європа мої зміни тис а зради
можете вигляд ніби сили шиза в дикій
роботі з нашими союзниками в межах з
цим гордо саммут не схожі на дешево
образитися Великобританії видно з
прогнозом та банку англії брексит
виробляти до падіння економікою
обвалу курсу національної валюти
бабель шивана ближче не плебісцит вже
спливаючи на бізнес видно з досягненням
фонду берд з моно вихід валу до британії
змінити валовий внутрішній продукт
країна нацькує соткою закладено крученого я
віддала до британці зайдуть своєю ізоляцією
захар не шви витрати на таке коло до 300
мільярдів євро на 1 годину євросоюз менше
пост народжуючи відра звук і кликала до
британію так unable та широкої німецька
економіка витрачати ельки 0,3 впали
берліну dvd c втече з повернеться
бюджету та з на два з половиною мільярди
євро щоб компенсувати і втрату
братання речі з ним сиф проти виходу
валаку британії зі складу євросоюзу 78
досвід цих на замовлення dvrs pantene тиф
заявив і хочеться у Великобританії
погоджувалась а у європейський спин ноті
Петро йому і так званий брексит лиж і 13
адже сотки
риса владної британців
противники у брексит дорослі після
референдуму у нідерландів сюди
асоціації з україною, а головний захисник
членство в я з прем'єр-міністр девід
кемерон поки ви продумуєте за свої
тайо мені а в шарнірах він кай на 1000
mine цю ситуацію у нього є сатіш 10
ти живий